the man accused of shooting metro police
officer shea michelonis and leaving him
paralyzed pled guilty to all eight
charges today victoria saha is live with
an update near circus circus it's where
officer michelonis was shot more than a
year and a half ago victoria
yeah it's a huge shift in this case
because the shooter at ger san diego
stood by his not guilty plea ever since
he shot officer michelonis from across
the street right by circus circus
edgar samaniego is accused of pulling
the trigger toward the group of officers
as officer michelonis and a group of
officers were making an arrest during
the black lives movement protest last
summer near circus circus since his
arrest he has pled not guilty to all
charges surrounding his involvement in
the shooting including attempted murder
with a deadly weapon that changed
tuesday morning during a routine
calendar call our i-team learned
samaniego pleaded guilty to all charges
by this gentleman i use that term
loosely accepting his responsibility and
pleading guilty straight up to all the
charges i think that justice will be
done to the extent it can
when you shoot a police officer and put
him in a wheelchair for the rest of his
life district attorney steve wolfson
says samaniego could face at least 40
years behind bars for the attempted
murder use of a deadly weapon charge
plus the other felony charges against
him including three counts of assault
with the use of deadly weapon officer
shane mccolonis has been paralyzed since
that june 1st 2020 shooting since then
continuous support has come in from the
police community we all go out there
putting our lives on the line every
night
in fear that one of us may not return
and so
we treat each other differently because
of that issue
officer mcloone's family declined an on
camera interview with me but say that
they are happy to see this case move
forward the next steps will be
sentencing victoria zaha live local now